okay overtime Black Knight asks what
does the panel think of the polls
showing oh yes I saw this almost half
46% of Republicans in Mississippi
believe that interracial marriage should
be outlawed not surprising no return my
Mississippi Wow I'm surprised I'm
surprised in it they would say to a
pollster yeah I think interracial
marriage should be outlawed well you'd
think that when somebody rang up is that
excuse me do you think that interracial
marriage should be banned you might say
no if you look at the polling and these
are guess and these are the Mississippi
into our phones you know the
inteligencia the most the most potent
and resilient form of racism is is
against white people having sex with
black people and that's why they lynched
black men right it was that thing right
went nutty about and it's the idea of a
smear of race fear a date they load and
you know your black penis the poll yeah
that album under that rap album fear a
black penis you you're the rap expert I
just like that poem series everybody
loves a big black [ __ ] which is which is
which is true
you know the opposition to interracial
marriage in 1967 when it was finally
gotten rid of by the Supreme Court right
far higher than opposition today the gay
marriage were ten years okay marriage
hey when my parents married a Jew and a
Catholic in 1951 is when my parents get
married that was very controversial more
than black/white is today I mean neither
one of their families was very happy
about that mm-hmm
yeah it's funny though you know after I
noticed this with interracial marriage
it's also after the marriage becomes a
fait accompli then the families are like
not [ __ ] you know seriously like like
like a week later then they like they
forgot that they were so adamantly
against it was done they're like oh
you're a human being what I do it don't
you it was someone's are usually like a
Halle Berry type you know look that's
why people like it nature wants us to
mate as far apart from our gene pool as
we do right I've always wondered whether
the the real hostility to Obama comes
enough from eating black but by being a
product of a biracial marriage I think
in some ways certain people can cope
with black people more than they can
cope with people who are indeterminate
it scares them they want they easy yeah
right okay you think they want mos def
to be the president Thanks
better example I should kevin garnett
you got the show's over it's on internet
is glenn beck's departure from fox news
a sign that crazy is falling out of
fashion hardly no no he was apocalyptic
even crazies don't like to hear the
world is ending every day right and
that's what he wasn't every day you'll
listen to him the sky was right it was
and frankly it didn't fall so kind of
guy oh it came the same week that we
found out at Donald Trump being number
two in the Republican polls right sir
okay is how is it possible to have a
wall between church and state when the
church persistently attacks the state
that's what got me banned from
Afghanistan not joke right there
[Applause]
governor Spitzer would you consider
running for office again and making a
difference with financial reform well I
just want a TV show that works well you
got one of them I got one with that and
it does work it works terrific Leggett
but come on you wouldn't run again
wouldn't you
you should I got a TV shop thank you
tonight we to say yes there's so few
Democrats who say the things that
progressives want to hear and need to be
said and we feel like there's nobody I
mean on this budget debate it's that we
feel like and I just say nobody's
standing up for one side it's like the
the Democratic Party the Democratic
Party needs backbone and it has been as
somebody was a Democratic governor
democratic AJ it has been terrible to
watch the party drift not drift run so
quickly to embrace the other side and I
don't get it and I'm ashamed of it and I
just did I despair for where it's taking
our power see this some truth to that
but I used to think if you look at the
the stimulus package it had every single
possible liberal goodie in it okay
that's a huge amount of money we have it
in the last two years universal health
insurance achieved by a Democratic
president it was some point this to be
good at for an answer what the stimulus
package was not about liberal goodies
first of all about 40% of it was tax
cuts that the Republic Republicans
forced in the huge amount of
infrastructure investment green energy
why is infrastructure a liberal goodie
like him I can't even get
the stimulus package came on the back of
a major crisis if it has not happened
the chances are we really would have
jumped off that cliff along with the
camera it worked it worked because
Keynesian economics is right there you
know deliver let's wake up and say what
has to be said the Laffer curve is just
that and they're still preaching the
idiocy they created that's not right now
and it's Kevin Eliot I'm not denying I'm
just saying the logic in the details yes
but overall given the president and the
Democratic Party refusal to address this
debt I'm not in favor of the Democrats I
want them to get serious about get
balancing the budget they seem to be
utterly oblivious to this well I'd
rather deal with jobs health care and
taxes and then and yes we will and then
you know what growth is gonna generate
how we deal with the debt in long term
and put the tax back on those who can
afford it
not taking away Medicare from those who
need health care it will work it will
work
[Applause]